Annis is coming this might be dangerous
so let's put on our mean faces
[Music]
we're gonna need some help
all right kid ventured him
[Music]
the entire time on earth finals he only
ever had one call
to worry about half the universe we are
out of time
the end is near
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie I just love
that spider-man
tag in there all right kid you're an
Avenger spider-man knighted officially
by Sir Ironman as part of the Avengers
knights of the round table
I suppose Benedict Cumberbatch would
probably be the one to actually do that
he's really the only British one in that
gang but I suppose that Iron Man is the
real king of the Avengers if you're
gonna split hairs but there's just a
whole bunch of new footage in both of
these I think this was dropped during
the Halo World Championships so if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the Marvel
videos this is just the beginning
there's gonna be a whole bunch of
Deadpool there's an Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway that's going on the
screenwriters even revealed a whole
bunch of deleted Captain Marvel scenes
that will make it into Avengers 4 so I
think that also kind of confirms our
Captain Marvel post-credits tag in some
fashion so I'll talk about that after I
talk about the new footage and there's
also a lot of questions about other
WonderCon trailers too so there's just a
lot of stuff happening this weekend we
finally get some dialogue from Mark
Ruffalo as banner Thanos is coming so
that's obviously right after they find
him crashing through the sanctum if you
guys didn't read the comic book Infinity
Gauntlet classic story what happens is
the Silver Surfer basically gets his ass
kicked across the galaxy by Thanos he
crashes through the sanctum and issues
this warning so Doctor Strange is really
like the first avenger on earth that
finds out what's going on but because
this is gonna be like a
two-and-a-half-hour movie I think it's a
little over two and a half hours like
two hours 36 minutes or something like
that
they've condensed a lot of that story so
when he crashes through the sanctum
Ironman has already been there talking
to dr. strange about this grand cosmic
threat that's coming so it just so
happens that Ironman is sitting there
when old buddy Bruce Banner just crashes
right through we get some new guardians
footage this might be dangerous let's
put on our mean faces then you see
banner turn into the Hulk and actually
if you look at the background here this
actually looks like it's still back on
that as guardianship so I know there's a
lot of questions about what goes on with
the Hulk in this because as of the end
of Thor Ragnarok he had been the Hulk
the whole thing about him going back to
being Banner after being the champion of
Sekar is that he was afraid that he
wouldn't be able to turn back into
Banner
for becoming the Hulk he's like if I
turn into him again it's gonna be
permanent I just told you if I turn into
the Hulk I am never gonna come back
again you don't care so when we saw him
during the infinity war trailers he was
mostly banner to that last big invasion
of Wakanda like you see and talking to
Shuri here so there's a lot of Avengers
that have problems going on with their
head space or just really weird stuff
that only Shuri is probably gonna be
able to fix so maybe if she can help
them with their vision infinity stone
problem like the mine stone inside
vision said maybe she can also help
banner a little bit too if you can D
program the winter soldiers mind you
could probably find some way to help out
Bruce Banner with his two different
psyches with the whole personality with
the banner personality but remember it's
not gonna be a five-hour movie so I
don't know how much of that they're
gonna get into this and I'm not
expecting it to be too crazy because you
see that big invasion scene at the end
of the trailer and you see the
Hulkbuster 2.0 and I think by now we're
all thinking that yeah that's banner
inside of there the outriders overrun it
and that's probably when he turns back
into the Hulk so that's probably
happening towards the end of the film so
I'm expecting mostly banner during this
but it's fascinating to think that if he
starts out is the Hulk on the Asgardian
ship when Thanos shows up to take the
tesseract and get the space stone out of
it then what happens to make him turn
back into banner like does he get his
ass kicked so hard by Thanos that he
just reverts right back to banner
because a lot of the actors the
directors have actually talked about the
relationship between Thanos and the Hulk
and it's fascinating because it's not
something that we've thought a lot about
before hook is probably gonna fight
Kolob City and at some point because
they're like the two biggest members of
each person's Avenger style team they
said Hulk is impressed by Thanos his
strengths because he's so powerful and
Thanos is interested in the Hulk like
he's like wow this is actually pretty
cool he's even a little surprised by how
powerful Captain America is when he
holds back his gauntlet briefly here but
I think I think we've clarified this
scene here isn't so much Santos trying
to punch Captain America and Captain
America stopping him it's really Thanos
coming for vision and we do get that
other scene that sort of pairs from
later in that moment where he says time
has run out so visions getting ready to
get his ass kicked - in Captain America
is the only thing between them so
Captain America is like the linebacker
tries to get in tannaz's way so he's
really just reaching for Captain
America's head so that he can grab him
and just throw him out of the way and
get to the mine gem but the really cool
thing about this scene with vision
because obviously we think that Thanos
is gonna get the stone because he's
gonna assemble the Infinity Gauntlet so
at some point it's gonna have to happen
is they said that they shot it like an
actual horror film so obviously this is
a big action film it's more of a heist
70s style film because Stannis is going
around taking all the gems it's his
heist film but for a couple of different
scenes they sort of flip John rust so if
they haven't really done a Marvel horror
film before I don't consider blade a
horror film even though vampire films
are kind of like a horror sub-genre I
don't think that Marvel has done a
straight-up horror film before they said
that this scene will be kind of like
that playing out like a monster film
like jaws or something like that like
you have a bunch of people on the boat
you know where the monster is and
eventually it will reach them so there's
this tear that you feel as you're just
waiting for it to happen because you
know at some point the monsters gonna
show up and just wreck everything in the
comics vision did not have the mine
stone he just had a Sunstone that
powered all of his systems Thanos pretty
much just rips him right apart but a lot
of people forget that vision can self
repair so you just like put him in a
little pile by himself and he'll put
himself back together slowly you get a
little bit more this lead up to that
wakandan battle like a gland right
outside the shield and I love this shot
of them destroying the forest because
their army is so big and so strong like
it's literally like a bunch of
bulldozers running towards the shield a
little bit more of Doctor Strange being
tortured by what I'm assuming is ebony
maw like we don't get an actual shot of
his face like they're two completely
different shots in that last big trailer
but you see him whisper just a little
bit so if you're gonna send somebody to
fight Doctor Strange you can ascend
another magic-user that's
evany maw it's kind of hard to tell
where this ship is but it could be the
same ship where spider-man gets knighted
as an Avenger by Iron Man but no idea on
what the timeline is here I'm assuming
this just happens much much later and
it's them interrogating Doctor Strange
for the location of the mind gem where's
the other stone give it to us the end is
near and I love the way that they end on
Captain America screaming silently with
that singing voice over like there's
song going is almost like everybody's
screaming as Captain America looks like
he's gonna meet his maker the thing
about this though you have to remember
that there are a bunch of big twists in
the movie so everybody let me know in
the comments do you actually think this
is Captain America's last stand or if
you do think that he's going to die
during the next two films how do you
think that it's going to happen but
there's just a whole bunch of new stuff
in this so let me know what's your
favorite moment from this new footage
probably have to be spider-man being
knighted as an Avenger because he's sort
of like the fanboy that gets to go on
this trip like he's oh my god base is
there preparing for battle and that
other trailer like I can't believe this
is happening I'm so happy to be here but
talking about the Captain Marvel deleted
scenes that the writers were talking
about
they said originally they wanted Captain
Marvel to be a much bigger part of
infinity war but because she was so like
Captain America in her personality they
decided to just hold off and let her
debut during her solo movie and then be
a much bigger thing during Avengers 4
but it is sort of sync up with the idea
that the director said that Captain
Marvel is not really in Avengers
infinity war which is why I'm saying
post-credit scene like okay they might
tag her at the end of the film then when
they say she'll debut during her movie
that's when you'll really see her scenes
you get the origin story the big
explainer so that when she gets to
Avengers 4 you'll already understand
everything that's going on with her so
they don't need to spend a whole lot of
Avengers 4 explaining her backstory what
her powers are what she can do I do
wonder what her original plot was going
to be during infinity war like how are
they gonna use her if she was going to
be a much bigger character what'll
happen is is later tonight the Dragon
Ball finale is going to air series
finale last episode ever of Dragon Ball
super so I'll do a video for that funny
story Captain Marvel also has a Super
Saiyan mode it's called binary but the
visual effect kind of looks the same
thing as when Goku goes super saiyan so
while you wait for that click here to
rewatch the new Deadpool trailer and
click here for more new infinity war
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you